bonjour aurélien merci d'être notre
invité politique ce matin vous êtes
député du lot secrétaire général des
républicains on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par christelle
bertrand bonjour creissels gens rien
bonjour j'aimerai dit la dépêche votre
presse régionale bien évidemment
aurélien pradié on commence évidemment
par l'ukraine et vladimir poutine qui a
donc pris la décision cette nuit
d'attaqué l'ukraine dans un discours il
annoncé une intervention militaire des
bombardements se font entendre aux
quatre coins du pays comment réagissez
vous à cette attaque aurélien pradié
c'est une guerre est donc face à une
guerre il faut que nous ayons la
réaction nécessaire d'avoir beaucoup de
gravité parce que ce sont les civils qui
bientôt vont être exposés à cette
situation ensuite parce qu'il s'agit
d'une violation
intégral sans aucune nuances du droit
international et que tout cela est
inacceptable et je le dis je ne
trouverai aucune circonstance atténuante
aucune excuse aucun élément de
compréhension à ce que la dîmière
protéine est en train de faire il faut
qu'ils soient sanctionnés au delà des
mots au delà des communiqués de presse
politique il faut qu'ils soient
sanctionnés financièrement
personnellement on a passé cette étape
là désormais je souhaite que des
sanctions financières soit appliquée non
seulement aux banques publiques comme
c'est déjà le cas en russie mais aussi
aux banques privées et à vladimir
poutine personnellement à sa famille à
toutes celles et ceux qui gravitent
autour de lui il faut que nous cessions
d'accueillir dans notre propre pays
débiner dignitaires russes dès
aujourd'hui pas demain pas prêt demain
dès aujourd'hui se demander la
suppression des visas par exemple la
suppression des visas immédiate la
comédienne vous trouvez que les
sanctions n'ont pas été assez forte ce
jusqu'à aujourd'hui je m'étonne de deux
choses et je ne veux pas faire de
polémique politicienne sur un sujet
aussi grave sans cela je ne serai pas la
hauteur de la situation d'abord je
m'étonne qu'on était aussi naïf sur le
sujet et ont ont globalement
emmanuel macron qui depuis des semaines
nous explique que en faisant cavalier
seul il va régler ce problème là je
pense qui s'est cru beaucoup plus fort
qu'il n'est réellement il a commis une
faute en comprend vladimir poutine seul
rencontrera le meilleur petit nom parce
que c'est le rôle de la france ça le
faisan seul je sais pas si c'est une
faute ce tome péché d'orgueil et
probablement at il pensé qu'à ce
moment-là il allait lui-même pouvoir
s'interposer face à l'histoire séculaire
de la russie qui a toujours voulu
accéder aux mers chaudes et qui a
toujours voulu créer des incendies
autour des frontières russes pour se
protéger comme l'a dit mercredi le
prétend ça c'est sûrement une faute d'
immaturité diplomatique d'immaturité
politique sûrement une femme est
candidat en campagne
la diplomatie est toujours faible quand
vous avez des arrière pensées
électorales derrière
je pense qu'il en avait et sans cela il
aurait fait les choses collectivement et
oui évidemment en faisant les allemands
c'est à dire avec les allemands avec
d'autres nos partenaires évidemment en
menant cette bataille seule l'idée
sûrement pas si secrète que cela était
qu' il allait récolter probablement les
lauriers lui seul mais quand on partage
la bataille à plusieurs on partage
évidemment la réussite potentiellement
mais on réussit davantage et je pense
que c'est ce sujet là mais quand je
disais on j'allais au delà des manuels
macron lorsque eric zemmour qui est
d'une complicité totale avec le pouvoir
de vladimir poutine nous expliquait il
ya encore quelques jours à l'instant je
l'a précisé
l'intervention il était temps il était
temps mais quelle hypocrisie il ya
encore quelques semaines il prenait fait
et cause pour la demi-heure poutine en
disant jamais la russie n'interviendra
en ukraine la preuve à l'heure où il est
incompétent ce qui probablement le cas
ou alors il ya une vraie complicité
caché avec la russie c'est vrai pour le
front national jean de complicité je
pense des liens d'intérêts parfois même
financier avec certains partis
politiques lorsque le front national
s'est fait financer ses emprunts par la
russie ça a quasiment ému personne pour
moi c'était une faute patriotique que de
devoir agir et que l'argent c'est
l'exemple eric zemmour pour avoir des
liens financiers avec la feria c'est à
lui de le dire en tous les cas il a une
fascination pour la nuit poutine une
fascination politique pour cette espèce
de virilité de toute puissance on l'a
entendu tenir ces propos là depuis des
mois moi je vous le dis très clairement
je n'ai aucune fascination pour la
lumière poutine aucune ils ne
m'impressionnent pas a aucun égard c'est
le président de la russie et à ce titre
là il doit être respectée pour le reste
je n'ai aucune fascination malsaine pour
la puissance mise en scène de quelqu'un
qui aujourd'hui viole le droit
international si les sanctions n'ont pas
été plus forte vous pensez que c'est
parce qu'il ya des complicités au sein
du gouvernement ou au sein de la classe
politique mais ce n'est pas ce que j'ai
dit ce que j'ai dit c'est que d'abord il
fallait une gradation jusque là la
russie n'était pas militairement
intervenants aujourd'hui c'est le cas
qu'on arrête de tourner autour du pot et
désormais on prend nos véritables
décisions pour le reste je serais
malhonnête et aveugle si je ne vous
dirai pas que oui je suis étonné de voir
dans mon propre pays depuis quelques
années notamment pour la génération
une espèce de fascination
pour vladimir poutine assez collective
assez ambiante en réalité et je pense
que on paye on ne peut tout cela au fond
d'avoir accepté beaucoup d'écart de la
part de la demi-heure poutine si on
regarde avec un peu de recul depuis
quelques mois tout ça était assez
prévisible en réalité assez prévisible
et ce qui m'inquiète profondément au
delà de la violation du droit
international qui n'est pas un détail au
delà de l'avenir de l'ukraine qui n'est
pas un détail c'est quelle idée allons
nous donner à d'autres dirigeants du
monde
qui sûrement eux mêmes avec d'autres
territoires je pense à taiwan par
exemple
espérait pouvoir violé toutes les règles
internationales
un monde dans lequel plus personne ne
respecte le droit international est un
monde qui s'effondre nous avons la
guerre en ukraine aujourd'hui nous
pourrions la voir ailleurs
françois fillon n'appartient plus à la
vie politique et donc je n'ai pas à
commenter sa situation s'il appartenait
encore à la vie politique
évidemment je dirai ce que j'en pense il
n'appartient plus à lille à incarner
votre famille politique pendant très
longtemps il en était le candidat à
l'élection présidentielle
est-ce que c'est gênant en termes de
l'image que pour vous avez utilisé le
parfait même parfait le passé vous avez
raison il incarner ce n'est plus le cas
aujourd'hui il n'appartient plus à la
classe politique en revanche je le veux
être très clair lorsqu'on appartient à
la vie politique lorsqu'on a une
responsabilité politique nationale on
doit défendre sa patrie n'avoir aucun
lien d'intérêt avec la russie c'est mon
gars je sais c'est le cas d'autres
responsables politiques évidemment ici
en france mais c'est sûrement le sujet à
traiter il ya des inquiétudes aussi sur
l'impact sur les prix de l'énergie pour
les français quoi pour à cette crise et
notamment sur le prix du gaz bruno le
maire il se veut rassurant il dit que
les français ne subiront pas les
conséquences économiques des décisions
prises par vladimir poutine est ce que
ça vous rassure ou est-ce que vous êtes
encore inquiète ce sera difficile parce
que l'animé routine pourra prendre des
décisions de rétorsion
à notre égard y compris à l'égard de
l'allemagne mais ça pose une autre
question qui notre souveraineté savez
sur tous ces sujets donc nous ne sommes
pas en situation d'avoir à gérer ici ou
là dans le monde des guerres la question
de la souveraineté c'est un question
très conceptuel sur notre souveraineté
énergétique lorsqu on affaiblit notre
souveraineté énergétique en fermant la
centrale nucléaire de fessenheim on
devient plus dépendant notamment à
l'égard du gaz et du gaz russe et dans
des situations comme celle-ci de tension
on voit bien que des mauvaises décisions
politiques nationales politicienne
puisque quand emmanuel macron affaibli
la souveraineté énergétique de notre
pays en fermant fessenheim c'est pour
dit les un accord politique avec ses
petits copains écologistes de l'époque
bien on voit à quel point des accords de
coin de table politicards ans
aujourd'hui des conséquences
diplomatiques sur la place que la france
peut avoir dans le monde et je pense que
nos concitoyens doivent bien mesurer que
compris c'est lorsque nous les
républicains nous disions attention en
affaiblissant le nucléaire dans notre
pays on perd notre souveraineté on nous
regardait parfois un manière un peu
distante dans dix ans de ça ça nous
concerne pas dans notre vie quotidienne
et bien si on le voit aujourd'hui sa
frappe le rayonnement de la france alors
on voit que de nombreuses questions se
poseraient c'est l'escaladé à laquelle
on a assisté cette nuit est ce que vous
demandez un débat à l'assemblée
nationale
je sens les sujets il serait juste que
nous envoyons un parfois au second débat
sur
des sujets qui ne sont pas absolument
essentiel là il me semble que c'était un
sujet essentiel on a une contrainte
c'est que l'assemblée nationale termine
cette semaine son activité qu'elle peut
être reconvoquée sur un sujet aussi
essentiel et députés je pense que ce
serait légitime que nous ayons ce débat
là parce que c'est un débat qui engagent
notre notre propre nation et que une
fois de plus emmanuel macron n'est pas
le seul à représenter notre propre pays
la représentation nationale ont fait
aussi partie on va parler de ce qui se
passe dans notre parti vous avez journal
libération ce matin aurélien pradié
cette enquête qui est qualifié la
primaire des républicains de bide aux
adhérents mort victime ou fantôme cette
libération des gens éloignés de la
politique qui aurait été poussé à voter
même un chien délibération qu'est ce que
vous répondez à ça je réponds que ça
commence à bien faire et que moi ça
commence à me fatiguer ce vote du
congrès cette organisation que nous
avons eue elle a été exemplaire le chien
dont on parle n'a pas voté on a nettoyé
les listes électorales avant même qu'il
y ait une opération de vote et je le dis
parce que j'étais dans la machine avec
christian jacob qui a été d'une
attention extrêmement forte sur le
processus électoral on a mis en place
des systèmes de sécurité qu'est ce que
ça va danser nettoyer les listes
électorales c'est à dire que nous avions
des doublons nous avions des personnes
qui avaient donné plus de 10 fois le
même numéro de téléphone on avait des
personnes qui n'avaient pas donné
l'adresse qui n'avait pas donné de mails
qui n'avait pas donné le numéro de
portable et dont un est l'héritier
combien car on a supprimé près de 9000
personnes entre ceux qui avaient adhéré
c'est la liste que libération avait et
ceux qui ont voté libération fait une
erreur fondamentale c'est qu'ils
confondent la liste avant nettoyage de
la liste après nettoyage il n'y a eu
aucune contestation de ce scrutin aucune
vous trouverez peut-être un ou deux
types qui se sont amusés mais sur le
volume global de votants ça ne change
absolument rien tous les candidats
accepter le résultat et je dis ce qui ce
qui me stupéfait depuis plusieurs
semaines c'est là le déversement de
boues sur sur valérie pécresse tout ça
tout ça pour pour l'affaiblir de manière
minutieuse de manière assez ligne
d'ailleurs
libération avec toutes les informations
dont les leur avons donné je trouve la
pratique ce qu'a fait tout à fait je
termine l'argent bien sûr sur cela je
trouve la pratique tout à fait
malhonnête le scrutin a été transparent
il a été juste et aujourd'hui personne
ne l'a contesté personne ne le
contestera mais arrêtons sait jamais
avec certitude qui avait aucune fraude
durant le scrutin évidemment évidemment
on a fait tout ce qu'il fallait faire
est-ce qu'il y en a un ou deux sur les
centaines de milliers d'électeurs qui
qui qui ont été plus malins que les
autres peut-être mais le nombre
d'électeurs qui ont rattaché qui ont été
rattachées à un même numéro de téléphone
plus de deux fois ça représente moins
d'un pour cent du volume des lecteurs
même pas du volume de ceux qui en beauté
du volume d'actes
mais c'est absolument marginal mais
c'est produire les listes des électeurs
de manière allez allez comparer à
vérifier que ceux qui ont voté avait
bien le droit de voter ceux qui ont voté
avaient le droit de voter je vous le
certifie est ce qu on a eu notre
libération non non parce que libération
a volé à voler des listes auxquelles ils
ne devaient pas avoir accès et des
règles dans ce pays la liste des
adhérents est une liste protégeons zabel
est une liste protégez vous aidons liste
officielle devant ne cède pas à la
menace en l'occurrence c'est pas parce
que libération a commis un acte qui est
un acte répréhensible de s'être procuré
des listes qui était né liste protéger
et confidentiel que nous devrions nous
céder à ce chantage le redirai pas la
liste non on n'attend aucune raison
parce que c'est son et données
confidentielles et je rajoute que ce
scrutin a été fait dans les meilleures
conditions de la manière la plus sereine
et la plus transparente possible et
vraiment je le dis notre démocratie
mériterait un peu mieux à quelques
semaines du scrutin présidentiel que ce
genre que ce genre de polémique du zizi
liste salle est vrai tout soupçon tout
douté on tournerait la page on passerait
à autre chose ce que nous voulons
d'abord vous pouvez croire en ma parole
et en celle de christian jacob faire du
bien aussi de temps en temps nous croire
en la parole de responsables politiques
on n'a pas à priori d'une politique et
on n'a pas oui par d'autres on n'a pas a
priori des têtes malhonnête quand on
vous dit qu'on a fait respecter les
règles c'est qu'on a fait respecter les
règles la deuxième chose c'est
qu'aujourd'hui le débat politique il
doit se porter sur les projets
politiques ce dont il s'agit pour
l'avenir c'est pas de tel ou tel bidule
ce dentiste lui pour l'avenir c'est du
programme présidentiel et ce qui me
stupéfait aujourd'hui c'est que nous ne
soyons pas à la hauteur collectivement
de ce débat présidentiel la démocratie
mériterait mieux que ce genre d' enquête
à deux balles
[Musique]
oui le parti vert les écarts la porter
plainte dès aujourd'hui parce que les
règles n'ont pas été respectées 1
pourquoi du coup pour diffamation parce
que les propos qui sont tenus dans l'
enquête sont diffamatoires ils sont faux
et par ailleurs parce que on veut savoir
comment des journalistes ont pu se
ponctue rire se procurer pardon des
liste confidentielle il ya des règles à
respecter lorsqu'on est responsable
politique lorsqu'on est citoyen
lorsqu'on est journaliste aussi
wii qui a annoncé hier la tenue d'un
meeting à marseille le 5 mars est ce que
pour vous c'est une bonne chose et ce
qu'enfin on va pouvoir rentrer dans le
débat politique
cette campagne va finalement commencé
c'est devenu absolument vital pas pour
les républicains particulièrement aimé
pour la démocratie pour les français
c'est quand même fou que ce président
qui se dit courageux chevalier ce plan
que depuis plusieurs semaines cherchant
tous les sujets possibles pour rester
caché il va falloir qu emmanuel macron
assume son bilan et son bilan est
mauvais et je m'en vais raison et qu'il
entre en campagne pour le questionner
sur son bilan évidemment puisqu'il reste
planqué dans la citadella lisez donc
quand sa majesté acceptera de venir
jouer le jeu de la démocratie ça ira
quand même beaucoup mieux
la situation internationale c'est le bon
moment pour vous il peut dans les jours
qui viennent de rentrer en campagne
c'est nécessaire parce qu'on a une
élection présidentielle et qu'on a à
choisir celui ou celle qui va nous
représenter pendant cinq ans à la tête
du pays et d'ailleurs sur la question
diplomatique ça fait aussi partie de son
bilan que de voir questionner tout cela
je n'ai jamais vu mon pays aussi
fracturé qu'aujourd'hui je n'ai jamais
vu
mon pays aussi fatigué qu'aujourd'hui
tout cela on le doit à emmanuel macron
et l'enjeu pour valérie pécresse oui la
fracture elle pays méthodique de quelle
manière il l'a fracturée en dressant les
jeunes contre les plus âgés il l'a
fracturée en dressant les non vaccinés
contre les vacciner il l'a fracturée en
dressant les jets les jeunes contre les
autres en dressant ceux qui ont réussi
et contre ceux qui ne sont rien pour le
site et oui il a méthodiquement fracturé
notre propre pays et je pense que le
vrai défi pour valérie pécresse c'est
d'être la candidate de la concorde la
candidate du rassemblement des français
parce que rapprochons ce sujet de la
question internationale que nous
évoquions au départ si vladimir poutine
intervient aujourd'hui c'est parce que
l'allemagne est affaiblie au changement
de chancelier c'est parce que les états
unis ont d'un président qu'il a aussi
paré plus faible que ce que nous
imaginions et parce que la france est
politiquement affaibli est donc l'enjeu
de rassembler la france
de rejouer la concorde nationale c'est
aussi ce qui fera que la parole de la
france pèsera plus notamment sur la
scène internationale il ya la question
des parrainages qui se posent un qui se
posa beaucoup puisqu'il n'y a plus que
neuf jours maintenant pour récolter les
parrainages il devait y avoir une
réunion ce matin autour de jean castex
en tout cas le premier ministre l'avait
annoncé mardi devant les députés les
associations d'élus ont décidé de ne pas
y aller estimant que c'est trop tard
maintenant pour se préoccuper de cette
question une raison pour vous oui c'est
effectivement trop tard jean castex il
se réveille toujours un peu tardivement
les associations d'élus ont fait passer
les messages aux élus des responsables
politiques l'ont fait en disant que la
démocratie nécessité que les différents
candidats puissent se présenter trop
faim il reste une semaine un peu plus
d'une semaine quand même oui mais elle
met les messages les messages ont déjà
été passés dans fin je vais vous dire ce
que je pense au fond je pense que tout
ça c'est du cinéma
de la part de journée l'enjeu de la part
de marine le pen et de la part des
risées bon d'abord parce que on a déjà
vécu ça notamment dernière élection
présidentielle le petit numéro de
calimero on le connaît on connaît tous
sa pour finalement avoir ces parrainages
eric zemmour en fait à mon avis je me
dis comme je le pense des caisses sur ce
sujet y compris vous l'assurer pour
s'attirer quelques sympathies politiques
je tomberai pas dans ces qu'ils auront
les cinq sens je pense qu'ils auront les
500 parrainages je pense même qu'il les
honte aujourd'hui qu'ils ne déposeront
au dernier moment et qu'ils n'auront
plus de 500 vous le verrez le situer en
fait il en manque 50 pour la croyez pas
je pense qu'il ya une vraie mise en
scène de la victimisation d'ailleurs
c'est très curieux pour des candidats
qui se considèrent indépendantes
autonomes hors du système d'aller
pleurnicher dans les jupes des partis
traditionnels pour obtenir quelques
parrainage pas moi j'étais très curieux
de voir eric zemmour qui passe son temps
à pourfendre les appareils politiques
venir pleurnicher dans les jupes des uns
et des autres pour obtenir quelques
parrainage addictive s'est attiré
quelques sympathies politiques ça veut
dire quoi ah je pense qu'il veut
profiter de l'occasion pour semer une
confusion dans le pays entre les
parrainages les soutiens mais déjà par
exemple quand vous avez six sénateurs à
l'air qui ont annoncé hier qu'ils
parrainent eric zemmour pour vous vous
les comprenez ces sénateurs moi je suis
député les républicains je parraine la
candidate les républicains et si on
tient les gobelins ce parrainage c'est
un problème pour vous des sénats non
parce que j'espère que les français font
bien la distinction entre le parrainage
et le soutien politique mais je dis
juste qu'il y a peut être un peu de mise
en scène de la part d'eric zemmour et
puis je veux ajouter un point personne
ne s'interroge indien mais pourquoi ces
candidats n'arrivent pas à trouver les
parrainages 500 parrainages sur les
milliers de mères que mes deux grands
élus que nous avons c'est pas si
compliqué à obtenir normalement les
maires sont pas des apparatchiks les
maires ce sont des élus du peuple
extrêmement respectée par nos
concitoyens qui souvent n'ont pas
d'étiquette politique et peut-être que
leur candidature aux trois sont des
candidatures tellement clivante
tellement fracture entre pour la société
que des maires qui ont une culture
quotidienne de la concorde ne s'y
retrouvent pas et je pense qu'on devrait
interroger soins et tony qui n'est pas
les 500 signatures si vous dites je
pense difficulté pour les mères de il
faut qu'il les ait pour que le débat
démocratique puisse avoir lieu le fait
qu'ils aient des difficultés à les avoir
ça dit aussi beaucoup de leur propre
faiblesse politique en eas sur les
appareils politiques données parrainage
pas du tout j'en ai marre d'être élu
président à un public ne pas avoir
d'implantation locale ça a été le cas
d'emmanuel mac ronde mais il il a eu des
500 parrainages le vrai problème
pourquoi est-ce que maire d'une commune
de saint habitants aujourd'hui hésitent
à donner son parrainage à eric zemmour
marine le pen ou jean luc mélenchon pas
pour des questions d'appareil politique
puisqu'ils ne sont pas politisés ces
mères là mais simplement parce que ces
candidats ne ne sont pas l'idée que les
maires se font de la concorde nationale
c'est ça le vrai sujet et moi je pense
ce matin si un maire parraine eric
zemmour de manière républicaine inverse
l air en jeu par la mer les républicains
par un eric zemmour de manière
républicaine tout en soutenant valérie
pécresse c'est pas le problème non il
peut le faire mais je dis simplement que
vous ne m'entendrez pas
devenir le vrp de ces trois candidats
qui sont un foutu de trouver 500
parrainages braqué un moment il faut
qu'à venir les choses sont 310 david
lisnard a eu raison d'appeler les merdes
ah oui il a eu il a eu raison de le
faire je dis juste attention de ne pas
tomber dans le piège la mise en scène et
puis je redis
quand on joue les gros bras politique
comme ces trois candidats le fond on
vient pas pleurnicher auprès des partis
traditionnels pour obtenir les êtres ils
vont finir par nous être redevable de
ces différents tons il s'agit d'un
jardin les annexes en argué nous est
cette réunion tombent dans le piège je
pense que les gens médiatique à ce texte
veut se racheter une bonne conscience
avec ce sujet s'il voulait être efficace
il faudrait que monsieur guérini le
patron de la république en marge passe
le message à ses élus locaux pour donner
mes parrainages à eric zemmour problème
c'est qu'ils ne manquent pas d'élus
locaux dont ils ont besoin des autres un
dernier mot puisque françois xavier
bellamy annonce qu il parrainera et
règlements pour vos pas de problème non
plus il distingue bien le parrainage du
soutien des choses vont bien de la
question sur valérie pécresse christelle
oui
dans son programme elle propose
notamment plusieurs choses mais de
supprimer les droits de succession pour
95% des français question est ce que ce
n'est pas une prime aux plus riches
cette mesure-là d'abord ce n'est pas la
seule mesure vous le savez
l'augmentation de 10% des salaires que
propose valérie pécresse la question de
la pension de retraite jamais inférieur
au smic des mesures sur les allocations
familiales dès le premier enfant la
défiscalisation de toutes les heures
supplémentaires bref tous ces sujets
sont des sujets qui concernent les
classes moyennes et les classes
populaires le grand défi pour valérie
pécresse et elle l'a parfaitement
entente est notamment depuis le congrès
depuis la réunion le meeting du zénith
c'est de s'adresser à tous les français
y compris les plus fragiles valérie
pécresse elle a peut-être parce que
c'est une femme d'ailleurs une
sensibilité toute particulière à l'égard
des plus vulnérables dans notre pays et
nous sommes quelques-uns avec elle a
pensé qu' un des grands défis de notre
pays et de s'adresser aux plus fragiles
aux plus vulnérables qui sont de plus en
plus nombreux aujourd'hui ils sont pas
forcément les plus pauvres qui sont
aussi les classes moyennes dans le
projet de valérie pécresse il y à une
série de mesures qui concernent celles
et ceux qui aujourd'hui souffrent le
plus dans notre pays ce sont ceux à qui
eric zemmour ne s'adresse jamais parce
qu ils les ignorent et ce sont ceux à
qui émanait que emmanuel macron méprise
notre chemin pour nous la droite
républicaine c'est de s'adresser aux
catégories populaires
oui sur la lutte contre la pauvreté vous
avez beaucoup travaillé sur sur ce sujet
quelles mesures prendre à valérie
pécresse justement puisque vous disiez
il faut qu'elle s'adresse aux plus
fragiles terminé hier quinze jours
d'auditions au quartier général de
valérie pécresse sur la question de la
pauvreté avec toutes les grandes
associations dans les jours qui viennent
valérie pécresse foire à des
propositions sur ce sujet notamment sur
les enfants de pauvres sur un pays dans
lequel les enfants pauvres sont de plus
en plus nombreux qu'est ce qu'elle
valait un grand pays comme le nôtre ne
peut pas se satisfaire de cela on va
travailler sur l'éducation l'a déjà fait
des propositions de très fortes pour que
l'école soit un véritable outil
d'ascenseur social sur l'accès à
l'alimentation sur la question du
logement sur la question de la
parentalité je lui laisse parce que je
ne suis pas comme dans la présidentielle
le privilège
faire ses annonces là mais ce sera le
cas en plus de celle qu'elle a déjà fait
sur ce sujet dans les semaines qui
viennent il faut que l'ascenseur social
fera ses annonces chef vous le saurez
dans les jours qui viennent je serai
heureux de vous en reparler merci
aurélien pradié législatives à nouveau
c'est une bonne question je l'annoncerai
dans quelques jours et la presse locale
sera un format on l'apprendra avec
christelle alors merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
[Musique]